she is the future of UFC commentary she
is an absolute Superstar on Dana White's
Contender series it's Laura sanco we
flew all the way from Kansas City to
feed her Stout Burgers on this week's
food truck Diaries let's go
[Music]
I need everything I get super thick boy
used to have a model [ __ ] now I got a
thick one yeah I do last night went late
yeah we had a sick one yeah and I like
the Kansas City Superstar herself thanks
for cutting some time out of your busy
ass schedule man Laura sank out here I'm
excited to be here I uh I'm not gonna
lie I mean I watch the show a lot and
when you guys first contacted me I was
like me me yeah you don't realize how
big of a star you are yet no I'm really
not nothing better but I was what I was
saying before we started um as I'm
eating my own hair um it's it's fun to
be the interview subject not to
interview her yeah you get to relax a
little bit yeah and you're coming
straight from the contender series I
know straight to Calabasas from the
condensed Series in Vegas Contender
series is interesting I think it's the
best idea the UFC's had in a long time
it's completely taken over like the
ultimate fighters is just not what it is
anymore and the contender series which
you know when you first started like ah
let's see how it goes and to me it's by
far the best product UFC does because
thing about all the superstars that have
come out of the contender series and to
me what makes it more special than the
ultimate fighters those Fighters are so
hungry to get a contract and they're
also ready to go anything about the
superstars like sugar Shawn came out of
there and now I think and which I'd love
to pitch this idea to you Beau Nichols
you right like so it's like well don't
let me in anything with bow nickel but
that's very that's very comfortable well
I think but I'm just saying as far as
like the super yeah the platform the
superstars is kind of taking over what
The Ultimate Fighter used to be so it's
creating all these super listen I'm an
ultimate fighter alumni I'm Ultimate
Fighter it gave me my ticket to the
Chocolate Factory I own the Wonka
Chocolate Factory got CT but still it's
a cool Factory yeah I did get to go in
there and taste the candy and I got CD
from it but um yeah I just think the
contender series is just a special thing
and you being part of it I just think it
makes it that much better it's it's
definitely my favorite show by far I
mean have I've yet to work a
pay-per-view in like the full broadcast
capacity but there's something oh man
there's something so special and
Powerful about even just standing like
next to someone who has just made their
dream come true like I I think of it as
like labor and delivery nurses right
like they get to be there as new humans
are like brought into the freaking world
yeah but don't get like them because
they're so used to it they get jaded
they're like here's your kids you're
like here's your kid like mine she's
like me and my kids here you go another
one next you know you don't want to be
that yeah I don't think I could because
like there's definitely a part of me
that still because I because of what my
career was how short it was uh I live
vicariously through all of them even the
heavyweights the men women whoever like
there's a part of me that
loves what they're doing because I wish
I could be doing it so it's it's special
to me on like another level Beyond even
just loving people and wanting all
people to succeed yeah and also I think
because you were a fighter and you can
appreciate like what it takes for that
moment and also I think it's also rare
in people's lives like what's an actor
you might see him the breakout movie but
I'd rather see the audition how I got
them there you know or their their their
their acting classes I kept them
building up to it we get to see that in
the contender series it's like The
Ultimate Fighter you know when it was in
its Heyday like I remember when I
knocked out Marcus Jones I'm it's not in
my personality I'm doing snow angels on
the mat I go to grab and hug Dana White
he's like bro your nose like what he's
like your nose and I got need in the
nose by Marcus Jones my nose is like
over here I'm like oh my God but it's
like that moment like made my career
yeah and it's on TV so you get to be
involved in all that it's like now you
have super stars coming out of there
it's like a weekly it's like a weekly
drug rush I don't do drugs so maybe
that's the wrong analogy but yeah I talk
to the people that do it sounds like it
um that's so fun uh it's like to be to
be any part of that is just awesome and
this man the stories that come out of
that show like the backgrounds I get
really sucked into the backgrounds that
people have because I think it matters
like it matters more when you watch them
go on and do big things well it's like
if you watch I'm interrupted it's like
if you watch like uh the countdowns the
embeddeds or like the the 24 7s that HBO
used to do like I don't even know this
Mexican fighter and I'd be completely
sold like his life story selling tacos
got in a fight with his brother they
realize he had a good left hook and then
you know he comes from nothing like I'm
in man so I think with Contender series
they're just selling these stories and
it's such a special thing but it's don't
discredit it's I think it's the perfect
storm it's exactly what the UFC needed
the ultimate fighters ran its course
that's over so then this thing you have
these hungry Fighters and they're
putting on fights because they know if
they do their job they get the ticket
right there you're part of it you got
Biz being there Felder who is it Brent
is Brendan Fitzgerald
Brandon knows half of it and then Dan
Halley will call half event s they're
all great yeah so it's like this perfect
like teamwork man and then Dana's
passionate about it you know it's such a
cool yeah that's his baby and I I like
the format of it it's it's short like
it's a palatable amount
I'd like to watch every moment no
especially I'm a giant 100 giant
pay-per-view card but this is two and a
half hours not a lot of fluff and I love
that people they go out there swinging
for the fences man because like you said
it's a different assignment they they
will I'll watch tape on guys a lot of
tape on guys coming into those fights
and they will fight so far beyond their
own style because of what's at stake and
it's going to show off the seat they do
and then also you know I think it's cool
because you get to be there when they
get their moment and then you have to be
proud of guys like sugar Shawn all the
other guys have made it because it's
like oh that's my guy yeah like I we did
this man yeah I'm I'm old enough I'm not
I'm not old enough to be all of their
moms but it's starting to be to the
point where I'm old enough to be a
couple of their moms and it's really
kind of freaking me out not so much Sean
yeah but uh you look back at that
interview I did with Sean and he's just
he looks so different his energy is
different I mean clearly the skills were
there swag was that but it's like you
brought out this like this awesome into
this incredible character and he
actually came back last week and sat in
with us and called a fight and he was in
the production meeting and he sat down
and he was like this is so cool he's
like this is what this is where we got
our stuff you know like I so I kind of I
feel like I share a bond with all of the
fighters there and so and that's
becoming a bigger and bigger and bigger
proportion of the UFC because I've been
involved with every episode of that show
it's my I love it and it's Dana's baby
but yeah it's your baby that's what yeah
yeah it's like you share this you know
stepchild but
um I think too I'll get off contention
series notes after this but I I think
I'm a huge Bo nickel fan I think he's
the future I think he's the biggest
Prospect we've had in uh probably 10
years the only closest one would be
Aaron Pico we signed with Bella orbit
bow Nichols is right there like if he's
a stock I'm in and when I watch him he
only has what two fights three fights
two now yeah two now and yeah I think
they announced the third in September
end of September right when I look at
Beau Nico I'm like well he does need the
experience because once you get to UFC
UFC is not a place where you want to
pick up experience because you get
thrown to the freaking Wolverine's
draftsman so for Beau Nichols and
condenser is such a big thing I don't
get why and hear me out here you know
the ins and outs of condensers why why
not make bow nickels like the champion
of contender series because it is a
feeder League he's a champion of That
League and then just have him get
experience in there and then graduate
him to the big loots you know I think I
I think Daniel's all shut up yeah
I think he's ready to be honest with you
I think that I think that they knew what
they were doing a putting him on that
show because that show allows you to
have a little bit of jet fuel when you
come into the UFC you're fighting in
front of Dana you have that clip of Dana
talking about you when he gives you the
contract obviously the fight has to
speak for itself and it certainly did
yeah I want to see him challenged uh in
week nine at least to the extent that he
can be you're not gonna feed him to
like I want to see him I want to see him
go past what
past two minutes something like um I
don't know if you're gonna get that at
that level Contender seriously unless
it's like a vet you know do you see here
I am turning into the interviews
I made this argument I think it was on
the weigh-in show I think he could
compete at least at the beginnings of
the top 15 in the middleweight division
today 100 now my if that's why he
doesn't need to be champion of the
contender series I'd see I did three
because it like can he compete in the
top 15 absolute would probably be you
know a good amount of them I'm not gonna
count names we'll probably beat a good
amount of them but my goal for Beau
Nichols to be world champion he's he's
not ready to be world champion that
didn't happen no so in order for him to
get that experience he needs to work on
his striking doing condensers yeah don't
do in the UFC you know so I I think
again he beats a lot of those top guys
right now but I would ask Beau and his
team like well what's the goal yeah if
the goal I don't know if money's an
issue if money's an issue let's get to
the UFC get your sponsors do all that
stuff but if your goal because the UFC
is a marathon not a Sprint we can do a
Sprint and you're gonna be flashing the
pen in and out then you're teaching kids
wrestling but if your goals become the
straight up world champion multiple
times let's hold out let's take a little
break from chat and Laura sanco's air
off so he can still stare at my ugly mug
because I got something for you guys for
you bros out there those pumpkin spice
lattes are popping it is tis the season
but listen when it's the season that
fall Breeze is just passing you by you
don't want to Bush fellas that's why you
need manscape that's right manscape
products to trim your balls with ease
and Today's Show is brought to you by
manscape but company here to make sure
that your your bush isn't the only thing
shedding it's excess leaves all right
heck even Mother Nature knows it's time
to lose the excess clutter from the fall
join us 6 million Bros worldwide who
trust manscape by going to manscape.com
for 20 off and free shipping with the
code shop 20. what do you get at
manscape well that's hilarious you guys
should know by now do a million reads
for them whether you're brand new
already with the team at manscape you
could use the crown jewel of care for
your family jewels we're talking about
the Platinum 4.0 package in this package
you get everything you need to stay
hairless like a cat those hairless cats
not like regular cats you know those
weird cats and those movies you know
what I'm talking about anyways you get
the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer the weed
whacker nose and air here trimmer also
if you have hair coming out your nose
you look like a psychopath uh you also
get the additional body wash and Ultra
Premium two in one shampoo conditioner
all right you get the premium deodorant
you also get the crop reviver the crop
preserver you also get a nice little
shed travel bag to put all those goodies
into that's what you get with this
Platinum package from my friends at
manscape all you gotta do go to
manscape.com get 20 off and free
shipping with the coach shop 20. that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com we use code shop 20
manscape cut out the leaves it's your
tree trunks time to shine let's get back
to the program but look
look how
the ranks and is on the precipice of
the Savoy body
able to survive
a decent amount of time and gain some
experience and start like picking up new
skills in the UFC Charles Oliveira is a
much better example much much better
example but it took him forever forever
and he went through the ringer go back
to chase Hooper though
I I would say he was mismanaged
I think he got there a little bit early
but like he wasn't ready for the like he
I think he beat a lot of guys not in the
top 15 that's not happening but he can
beat a lot of those guys on the outside
there but again what's the goal chase
you know but look at this
I think there's a real path for Bo
nickel because he's not going to get
right into the UFC and start you know
fighting top 15 guys I don't know how
big that it depends but I do think the
UFC is learning you know because I think
they rushed Darren Tillman yeah
we broke you know but I do think he can
come back as a skill set the mindset for
it but they've rushed guys but look what
they're doing with sugar Shawn they've
taken the time now you know he's one of
the top five Sean's a perfect example
Sean's good Patty pimlets a great
example
Patty film's a great one where they're
not brushing him like with Patty like oh
we want to see him against it's a dude
he's just getting going I can chill I
think that they will they will handle
Beau the way that bow should be handled
and and Beau will pass the appropriate
test when he needs to pass him but I
mean listen we've listen we've seen what
is it Kane Velasquez had two fights when
he came to the UFC Stellar NCAA
Wrestling background Brock Lesnar
amazing NCAA background
yeah let me
you're talking about a different animal
now we are like not like the games
Advanced so like there's so many good
guys different weight classes the skill
set yeah and someone is gonna be able to
stop his taked guns I guarantee yeah
that's gonna happen and it's a matter of
the top ten that wrestling to a certain
point is you know now there's the khabib
argument right like khabib striking not
not awful but you know he's not Charles
Oliveira so you know maybe maybe I'm
wrong now listen I'm I want to be very
upfront I'm all in on boat [ __ ] I've
never been more excited about a guy
since here in Pico no I understand like
you you want to succeed yeah I think
he's gonna want him to be I just want to
chill a little bit no I get it I get it
it's like when you drafted quarterback
in the first round and you know you play
for [ __ ] Jacksonville yeah it's like
I'd rather my guy like if it was my son
I'd rather than go to like you know I'd
rather than go to Green Bay and sit
behind in Rogers for four years pick up
the skills and then because you know
it's such a short window you talk to the
guys at ATT though like those behind the
scenes conversations talk to Jorge talk
to whoever and they're like no legit his
his striking he just hasn't had a chance
to show it that seed that see that's
what gets me excited yeah that like and
it was the same with Leon Edwards like
uh Josh Thompson you know he's the
captain of AKA and he's like dude I'm
telling you Leonards was with us for a
while
Savaged it and with machachev same thing
he's like no no I'm telling you like
those to me that like the training room
like kind of mythical Legends I that's
what I that's why I do this yeah I love
them I love them so when I heard about
Beau Nichols I'll keep going I'm selling
oh let's throw them yeah get them in
there yeah I just think it could be cool
if he was like the face of uh Contender
series and like I just feel I'm in more
Fame and just he will be for the season
listen I mean like nine or ten I can't
remember what week it is I think it's
week nine uh so four weeks from now he's
gonna fight again
obviously we expect him to do great
things yeah
I just don't see a point in making him
do it a third time you know I mean like
I also think it also four fights outside
where he'll get that another Year's
worth of experience and then off to the
race after racist I can't wait yeah I'll
be the first one by a shirt but I'll
design your shirt it's my thing I'll be
your guy but I also think too you know
the the caveat to that is if I'm in the
UFC meeting I'm like well dude Bo's
gonna destroy anyone we bring through
here so we can't build up any other gods
yeah he's going to eat them alive and
these guys are going to get to the UFC
so [ __ ] up the whole process yeah say
less keep doing what you're doing
they're like we also slowed for four
billion dollars shut your yapper shop
Fair Point Fair Point they figured a few
things out yeah they know what they're
doing this show in particular is an
interesting it's an interesting influx
of talent because so many people get
signed over a 10-week period and it's
very much like hey you proved to me in
this one night
sometimes you prove to me lots of things
because it was a three-round war and I
got to see grappling I got to see
striking I got to see your heart
whatever sometimes you just knock a guy
out in 30 seconds you impress me like up
to you right but it's still not like
that's the other caveat to that show
like that's still not the real UFC you
know what I'm saying like they they
think it is I'm it is I find that exacto
it is not you know it's like once that
crowd there and it's you know you're
talking about 30 000 screaming fan like
that's the real UFC that's why guys
like like Patty and there's some guys uh
that have come through
I'm trying to remember who it was if it
was dracus duplicity or he didn't come
through Contender series but like there
are some guys that have are lucky enough
to have that experience at
shows whether it's in Europe or South
Africa or whoever that sell out like a
guy that a lot of the Polish guys that
uh fight it is it ksw yep they I mean
those shows are like 15 000 people uh
and I to your point I didn't know Patty
was on that level we did a food truck
whether I'm talking to his manager and
he's like yeah Patty you know he really
didn't want to come to you I've seen
like why why not he's like oh dude he's
sold out yeah he's telling me like the
Arenas he sold out before this like he
was like he's taking pay cut but you
know we sing in the long run like oh
[ __ ] yeah oh and when his first UFC
fight I was like we're gonna see how he
handles with the nerves and for the
speak of a crowd and his Liverpool fans
like hey [ __ ] he's been fighting this
for four years selling out being the
only headliner that crowd at the March
UFC London show was
insane top five best events I've ever
seen and not even being there just watch
them like this is nuts for fight night
and wild absolutely wild I mean when I I
interviewed Dana after the fights and he
literally was like he was soaked in beer
he's talking like this because his voice
was completely gone from from yelling
and he's just like I just love this [ __ ]
how could you not yeah that's a special
right all right let's get off Contender
series because this is about you it's
about you for getting you know you got
your start on Contender series but
really really your origin story starts
with Invicta yeah which is you know the
the major leagues for female fighting
like there's not a bigger league but
you're it's interesting to me and we
have a lot of similarities which we'll
get to but so you start an Invicta as a
fighter you have a professional fight
there you win but you get pregnant so
that throws a wrench and everything yeah
and then you take care of the kid oh
shout out to you being a good mom which
is expected appreciate it yep so
appreciate it so then
the owner of Invicta was like hey you
want to do this interview yeah and
you're like oh I don't have any
experience with doing that none which I
think is the best way to learn by doing
it I mean it was scary yeah yeah no I I
agree I
you nailed it I
I thought I was going to be a a
professional MMA fighter like that was
my goal at Adam way that was who I was
um and this is right around the same
time
I thought right before Rhonda made it to
the UFC so like at that time I'm like
well this is it this is the top of the
mountain Invicta because we were still
under the impression that UFC would
never have women right Dana did say that
he did and then she changed everything
and uh so I had the fight
I was in Camp for my next fight got the
win in Camp for Max fight people are
excited about stuff I'm excited about
stuff and then you know the the joke
that I like to beat in the ground I had
to pull out because my husband didn't
got pregnant I know right live alone
like 50 times I dig it
um
and then she called Shannon Knapp called
and was like Hey Marlo's [ __ ] is coming
to town we don't really have
a sideline reporter would you be able to
interview her and I literally said
Shannon I have never held a microphone
I've never looked at a camera you've had
no desire to do it either never thought
about it
no not not the television part of it I
wanted to stick close to the sport and I
think I knew as soon as I got pregnant
that
being a champion and Invicta and because
still as an out of weight
which is I could I can't compete with
UFC straw weights I never could like I
weigh 118 right now and I'm not in
between that stuff so
if the top of the mountain for me was
always going to be Invicta and making
three and three or whatever
I had another career in Venture Capital
like I had other stuff going on and I
really wanted to dedicate I wanted to be
a mom yeah like be it's about the kiddo
exactly that's bigger than yours so I
saw that I saw the chance like well
maybe this will allow me to stay
intertwined and included in the sport
that I love so much and I can I can
still be there and just not in that
other capacity so I took a chance and I
guess they liked it and so they had me
doing the live post fight interviews so
I literally learned how to do anything
on television by myself by trial and
error live on UFC Fight Pass it's the
best way to go horrendous to go back and
watch yeah I hear you that's how it is I
mean if it wasn't bad you're just a
complete narcissist if you're like it's
actually pretty good Jesus Christ I
remember calling my husband after I
think it was Invicta nine if you guys
want to find it on Fight Pass and watch
my post fit interviews I'm gonna bring
you the insert here I called my husband
I was like Hey so how'd I do and he's
like well
he's brutal he's so honest he's so
honest does he have any background in
any TV anything he's an ex no but he's
an extremely educated MMA fan and an
incredibly smart guy
like
so honest it'll hurt your feelings oh
yeah sounds like my friends yeah and
he's like well he's like you did good
you sound it kind of sounded like you
had a stroke
because you were he's like you were
talking so slowly and I looking back
usually would be the opposite I know I
was so worried about being too fast
slowed it down and tripping over my
words that my
delivery was a lot and the fighters are
like like
this
like Walter Cronkite or something yeah
the energy is like come on
so I would rather have that than the
speed I see I dig it I'm not mad at it
right now yeah God because usually
people do the opposite yeah like
stand-ups if you can tell they've only
you're in it's like flying other
pendulum swung the other way after you
said that yeah and then you watch the
next one I'm like sound like
terrible like the micro machine guy they
sound like you're sipping on scissors
just on lean they're like what is wrong
with Laura yeah so it goes from uh
Invicta and then where the UFC sees it
because you got a big viral moment when
uh the girl kissed you yeah Tanya kissed
you on the lips and then that goes viral
and then but I would assume that's not
why the UFC called I don't think it is
absolutely not I don't no no I mean I
don't think it hurt that I handled it
well
um you had fun with it convicted being
on UFC Fight Pass you know they they
watch those and any property and there's
lots of them now so many now they watch
those like the producers and the people
that make the decisions about who's on
the broadcast team and really even like
Sean and Mick they're they're pretty
integrated into all of those oh I know I
was on the first show for UFC now and I
started talking [ __ ] about Reebok and I
was like yeah they won't see this oh
yeah they see everything that's my job
yeah so yeah anyways um yeah don't do
that not that you would so then they uh
they see you're working Invicta and then
you got called up to the big leagues
yeah so they a lot of people think that
my first UFC gig was a contender and it
was early but I actually was working
with fox fox yeah so I they called me
and they said hey
um would you like to come audition for
uh for Fox and that whole experience let
me tell you I've been through it I know
Wild
wild I was not prepared for that and
they auditioned me as an anchor so like
I'm dealing with multiple cameras and
addressing uh analysts and either in
your ear yeah producing here in the back
you're gonna start on camera one and as
soon as you start explaining it you go
to camera three you're like why in the
and I've never done a voiceover I have
no idea how to read the rundown of when
I'm supposed to talk
no [ __ ] clue about any of it and the
night before I remember my analysts were
Stephen Thompson and
I think it was Tyron now I'm forgetting
but I I literally cut out
I went on the internet with my travel
printer yeah and I cut out pictures of
them
and printed them and put them on pillows
and like yeah like set up the couch
because I've never done it before yeah
like I gotta figure out how to like yeah
do it look over at people and integrate
them that's how bad you want it that's
how bad so it must have went well no it
went horribly could have gone worse than
mine no way
I want to bet but my audition was
um it wasn't live on air but it was like
a pre-show it was Game audition it was
taped and it was Chael sonen and I
forget who else might have been uh I
forget uh Karen Bryan and Chelsea and
Karen Bryant and I struggle with names
sometimes it's just I'm not great at it
and it was an all Brazil card and the
juicier from Mega which I didn't say now
I I'm I'm destroying the names and I get
done oh it was a for major I'm like
Jesse uh and and I Can Tell She's in
Jail's my boy was like come on I'm like
I'm trying what the f it's in [ __ ]
Portuguese dude who does this to a guy
yeah like in the back in my my agent
manager they're like
not great not great yeah so I cried uh
in the area on the way home did you
really oh yeah yeah yeah I I they
intentionally threw me curveball I'd
also never read a teleprompter before I
had no idea yeah and so I am reading the
teleprompter and they intentionally put
the wrong script in there just to see
how it handled it if like I did not
seems like somebody didn't want you to
get the cake I think they were just
seeing like just some ugly producers
uh I didn't Rob I did not Ron Burgundy
like I caught it as I'm reading it but
you know during your year you're reading
one thing your body's trying to say
something else I could go back and find
the team you know I am Chael sonen yeah
yeah so then so then eventually you get
in the UFC via Fox same I was working
with Fox yeah and then uh then the
container Series starts yes yeah us so
they did call me after that and it was
kind of like a well you clearly aren't
an anchor yeah but you also clearly
really know the game and we've seen
enough of your working in victim would
you like to be a reporter so I started
doing the backstage reporting roles
first for Fox and then probably a year
and a half after doing that
um was when sit in the parking lot at
Target and got a call hey we've got
Kansas City yeah we got this new show
and
um we need someone that's good at live
postified interviews because that's the
thing too is like there's definitely
difference between the ones on Fox or
even ESPN usually got like five ten
sometimes more than five to ten minutes
to like think about an interview that
you're gonna have and think about what
you want to ask them as opposed to this
fight just happened you've got 20
seconds to get your ass in there and ask
some intelligent stuff get what we need
and do it and get what we need yeah and
have have enough understanding of the
sport that the fighter is going to
appreciate the questions that you're
asking them about the fight that they
just correct how are you feeling yeah
it's a different animal like
in in that type of post interview the
bullets are live yeah so they they uh
felt confident I could do that and then
what happened was honestly I can't
remember it was the first year or if it
was just a ways into the first year
Dana never likes to listen to the
commentators he likes to watch those
fights and just let them speak for
themselves and for some reason he threw
his uh his ears in and I guess heard one
of my interviews and I remember sitting
in the back it was at the it was at the
Tough Gym and it was I'm not making this
up
93 degrees
back where my little like spot was
sweating buckets so uncomfortable I got
this text from Dana White I'm like oh my
God I can't believe Dana White has my
number like how's this happening and he
just goes wow you really he always cuss
he's like you really [ __ ] know your
[ __ ] you know like you literally just
asked everything I wanted to know about
that fight
keep it up and that was the beginning of
the catfish no is this a bro yeah no
because he said yeah because he talks
like that but yeah you know he texts
that's a good point I actually did I
should have this is so fresh this is the
head of Sigma Pi what's happened yeah he
just talks like even more yeah yeah yeah
no and then uh I can't remember if he
came up to me after the show but
something kind of continued with that
conversation where from that moment on
it was like he he kind of respected what
I was doing yeah you can tell he
Champions you and the I think one of the
qualities of Dana is once you're in and
he vouches for you're in man yeah you
know and you got to do that but you have
to have the skill set yeah that's the
thing like if he's gonna back you up you
have to have the skill set which you do
I I'm working on it like I you're so
humble and I appreciate it you have the
skill set and I told you before you
started this
it it frustrates me they don't have you
doing more well thank you because you
like I don't know why you're not in the
fight nights I don't know why you
haven't done a pay-per-view yet it just
it doesn't make sense to me
well it would be so refreshing it's like
we're just gonna keep doing the same
thing over and over when you have the
chops to do it there are
it's a layered
why that hasn't happened yet for sure
and I'm sure I don't know many of the
layers you don't have to worry about Let
Me Be frustrated about it if I was your
manager I'd be super frustrated but you
don't need to work you just need to keep
doing what you're doing and I guarantee
it happens I I am manifesting it daily
let me tell you I we should do a bet hey
David here's a bet if Bo nickel fights
with the championship she gets to be the
analyst oh there we go there you go
there we go there we go I I used to um I
used to pack
I I haven't always done this but like
since it became my like mission in life
to call a fight and before they let me
do it for contender series which was a
huge win like that was that was the
biggest hump I needed to get over I just
needed to be able to show them I could
do it because I had I had a color
commentary audition as well about three
years ago that they just destroyed
we're like let's don't The Voice still
you know nothing about this is good and
then I'm like well got a lot to work on
let's get to work and then did you get a
heads up when they made you the the
first female analyst in the UC no no I
got about 12 hours notice
sometimes that's good it was you can't
overthink it I think because of what had
happened with LFA earlier that year uh
when Pat militic Uh stepped away from
the LFA and they needed people to fill
in there and Alan joban and I stepped in
and I actually stepped in super late
like they kind of already had Alan and
then they're like oh yeah we'll throw
Laura in there too that's a story in of
itself because
and I don't mind I don't mind I don't
mind sharing this because we've talked
about a lot and it's funny now but
uh they kind of they kind of messed up a
little bit and like didn't tell the
producers that they were bringing me in
to do commentary I thought Pat was still
there no they thought it was going to be
Allen filling in for for patch just
Allen just Allen so I literally drive my
ass to Wichita I'm like watching fight
footage I should never ever ever do that
but awesome but also it was important
yes um and it's Wichita not a lot
between Kansas City Wichita pretty safe
a couple deers
um so I arrived
and like Ed Suarez is like hey
just some issues like like come talk to
me when you get here I was like all
right so I walk into this room and
there's like
11 men sitting around this table and
including the producer and they
literally went around and were like this
is why we don't think you should
do this because they weren't prepared
for it they weren't sure I was prepared
for it more opposite of like the pat
military yeah and there's a pat like
buying a hot dog at the when someone
stormed the capital he's just in the
back like buying a hot dog he was like
what and like get him and he got fired I
don't even know what happened with that
to be honest he's like grabbing a pickle
but he just happened he did he had no
idea he was like oh there's a parade
today but that's a [ __ ] Legend and
like how do you how do you put this
random chick and like Alan whose people
weren't familiar with him in that role
either yes to fill in for freaking Pat
militants LFA is trying their best yeah
so I sit through this meeting and
they're like hey we're just we're gonna
have you call one of the Facebook fights
and then
and I'm like really like [ __ ] I drove
from from Kansas City to Wichita I'm not
doing Facebook and I'm not like I am not
good at those moments okay okay yeah
sure they can tell my face yeah yeah and
they're like but but you know we had a
lot of Hawaiian fighters on this car
dude maybe you could do like a little
report about how many Hawaiian Fighters
there are and in my head I'm like I have
this job yeah on ESPN yes for the UFC
like I don't and I very
I was so close to crying because that's
your story that's your story though and
I I
sat through the meeting in my mind I'm
like how do I handle the situation how
do I handle the situation without being
ungrateful without being a [ __ ] without
being understanding that's all sticking
up for yourself but also sticking up for
myself and being like no I I know I'm
good at this and so they have they like
have me step out of the room and have an
hour-long meeting about whether I could
do this 15 59 minutes too long and then
they finally let me do it and at the
ending of the story is like after the
show literally to a person all of them
became like we are
yeah and some of it you got to give them
a bit of a leeway there I did yeah I did
yeah
unless all of them had all the time to
watch to listen to me call the Invicta
because I went on I did commentary for
Invictus yeah but they don't know you
know they're busy everyone's busy and
they assume they know and sometimes you
can't assume yeah so I say that with
love because I love all those guys I
think the Ed Soares and I are super
tight yep he won't be he won't he'll be
like yeah that is that is what happened
on the bus because since then
they really are what helped Propel me to
get that Contender spot we're just going
to propel me into a fight night at some
point 100 and then you do the fight
night or pay-per-view and then come
directly here that's the deal all right
well you you're from Kansas City and you
guys know your beef out there we do so
we have Burgers today Stout Burgers it's
a food truck hopefully it's good
I mean you read me right I'm a Midwest
yeah I'm gonna I need me it's a little
pressure but you know we we gave Marvin
vittori Pizza you know
slightly maybe not racist but I know I
know trust me it gets nice yeah we've
had some guys where I'm like really all
right well uh let's see how the burgers
are and then we'll continue this talk
all right let's do the best let's do it
let's take another little break of you
guys watching me and Laura sank out eat
food man all right because you know
those times when you're so into what
you're doing can't think about anything
else those times when you're in most
focused and productive that's what we
call being in the zone or Flow State and
guess what you can get there whenever
you want With a Little Help from Alpha
Brain my friends at on it they have the
world renowned nootropic supplement with
over 1 million bottles sold Alpha Brain
promotes cognitive functions including
memory mental speed Focus yeah I'm on it
all the time man it can help you
remember names all right we all struggle
with names am I right or we just don't
care about that person but I think it's
more of a memory thing right that's
where Alpha Brain helps you out man my
boy Joe Rogan says he feels that it
helps him form better sentences when
he's talking you won't be like Joe Rogan
don't you just by Alpha Brain you turn
to Joe Rogan all right you might lose
your hair like him either way you'll
remember a lot of stuff Alpha Brain
contains amino acids and plant compounds
that promote the brain's release of
alpha waves which are associated with
greater creativity and productivity all
right they got you covered man also if
you don't like coffee it makes you
jittery or energy drinks make you
jittery all right this Alpha Brain has
it's caffeine free you don't have any
excuse man all right and if also if you
don't like it they give you your money
back you have no reason not to try Alpha
Brain all right uh if you don't like it
and if you feel it's not fit for you
tell them why and the refund your money
on the spot no return necessary we got
you covered man but you can save 10 on
your order by going to onnit.com
FTD for food truck Diaries right on
it.com FTD or swing by your local
Walmart all right and pick up some today
if you want to go to Walmart
or you could just order from my thing
all right on it.com
FTD it's also in the link in the bio or
you could go to Walmart
pretty easy choice right
links in the bio this episode of food
truck drives with Laura sanco is also
brought to you by my favorite Kratom on
the freaking planet the kratom's the
Wild West it's like CBD was about five
years ago you know who to trust you
don't know what you get in your bottle
but with my friends at happy hippo you
know exactly what you're getting and you
get in a variety of ways you get the
droplets you do the little simple shots
that they have you can do the gummies
the delicious gummies have all sorts of
fun flavors fun packaging but also what
matters not the packaging it's what the
Kratom provides for you it's my
Limitless pill whenever you see me doing
podcasts remember see me doing stand up
I'm on the Kratom son that's right it's
the best focused product I've ever used
and best of all it's natural baby visit
happyhippo herbals.com use promo code
thick boy for 20 off for life you can
use that code as many times you want
you're welcome you can create them at a
discount for the rest of your life
you're welcome happyhippo herbals.com
promo code thick boy 20 off for life
let's get back to the program
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna do I'm gonna do the shoe is it
good am I making a good choice um Sue is
actually an acronym for
so it's spicy oh it's spicy yes okay
well I I can do that like it's not crazy
spicy yeah
yeah crazy okay he has a kid I like kick
kicks yeah
um I'm gonna do the Goomba and then also
do a shoe too and she wanted the loaded
fries are you blaming that to me we're
gonna slip a load of friends yeah
yeah all right she also wants no one
else I wanted actually half of the
burger yeah
that's why I got to that's why too she
won half of it yeah I think that's it
brother
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's do it we hope he's these
past the Kansas City Bar it's a high bar
it's high bar I don't know if you know
that's about me but I actually sold beef
for a while so oh you used the same beef
so yeah I would sell it I took tout like
full cows uh that mine's upside down but
um
yeah I'd probably blame that on the
handlers I wouldn't sell like the entire
side of beef I actually like would uh
process it up and oh damn yeah was that
a good gig I feel like a good gig in
Kansas City not really there's no money
in food it was it was a passion a hobby
a passion project I also I here's the
thing about cat I'm you know I'm I do
eat beef it's my favorite food on
Carnivore diet usually is I eat a ton of
red meat but cows are [ __ ] cute they
are God they are it's really hard
especially like when we have bottle
calves that either lose their mom or
their mom doesn't accept them and then
you like form a relationship it's easier
when it's just like a herd and I'm
moving him and they just we just call
them by their number yeah and we don't
generally eat the ones that we have at
our place but every once in a while my
husband's vicious with it too is he but
did he grow up in that culture yeah yeah
it's something you got to grow up you
know what you're eating right now
no that's Betsy yeah that night Betsy
slept in the bed next to us right he
nursed her back to hell right I shot
bets in the face
you're I mean I mean hey man
good it was a good first bite here's the
spicy one
I think I'll start with the spice was it
nice is there is there a go-to place you
have in Kansas City Kansas City is great
barbecue we have great yeah I mean if
I'm looking for
meat for beef yes it's gonna be our beef
but you the one you like the couch yeah
yeah but
um no there's amazing barbecue in Kansas
City and it's never the places that
people tell you when they visit KC
either like if you if you come through
KC for comedy for whatever you got the
spot text me yeah
yeah because usually people give you
like the like the touristy
you want to go to the place that has
like the bars on the windows I want to
hold the wall you gotta go to City part
of town they have ribs only about 11 A.M
so for you how do they decide what what
shows you're gonna do and which ones
you're not like you have a schedule but
you know there's UFC in Paris coming up
there's yeah there's a million fight
nights there's you know there's also
like how do they decide all right we
don't really know
think I just get an email that says hey
these are the shows that are available
to you
do you want to do let me know oh
interesting and the tough thing is like
because all these spots are very
competitive
there's definitely a lot of pressure you
feel like if I say no
you know then how long is it gonna be
until you know that comes around so my
attitude for the longest time has just
been to say yes to everything I possibly
can manage and it's been a very hectic
couple of years but it's I feel like
it's paying off it'll pay off you do
your dues and then
because I assume with that schedule like
you're I mean you're you probably leave
do you get the same time Fighters do on
Tuesday like is it Tuesday through
Sunday or you get flying in like
Thursday Thursday
but during Contender series season like
if there's a pay-per-view
um out the door Monday morning
to come to Vegas for contenders on them
I catch a I get up at 3am on Wednesday
to catch a 5 a.m flight out of Vegas
Jesus to get home
put my son up from school
try to get some work done throw some
laundry in and then leave Thursday
morning early to go to wherever the
pay-per-view is that's a great get home
Sunday leave Monday get home Wednesday
it's hard it's a beast it is it is free
flyer miles like I do on Southwest oh
Southwest which you get a I mean I do
but there's no there's no like Lounge
Southwest not free for all it's just
like it's a Greyhound to the sky you
know like you're proud you're a but it's
also kind of sad but it's yeah it's like
this is the Pinnacle yeah like United
they really treat you proper I I flew
home from Brazil with one of the UFC um
he's the director
so like and he's been the director
forever so he has
stupid stupid amount of points I think
he called it was like Global Elite King
something I don't know they treat him
like royalty but he's like hey you can
be my guest
are you sure we rolled up to the airport
and it was like they knew we were coming
I never carried a piece of my luggage
there was basically no security involved
whatsoever TSA is bending the news yeah
yeah that's what I want they took you
like they took us on this cart and drove
us to the gate you get all the drinks
and then literally just like face palmed
everyone I felt so important it was
amazing I know and then it never
happened again and I went back you're
sitting that diamond first class and
you're judging everybody that walks by
it I did okay keep going okay convert
your eyes okay please don't all right
don't look over here all right let's not
get all the porn in the back yep I've
been there man once myself
um now we have something in common too
with the Ulta program yes so two uh
members of the thick boy staff both
George's George squared keto George tall
George two George so we had to figure it
out right
um they're both involved in that Ulta
program right here in Burbank
I'm these boys are six weeks in I'm so
excited about this program and I think
people like it's hard to explain to
people what it is but then once they see
it they get it and to me it's like it's
a combination of
remember that like rock star of Fantasy
Camp where you can pay a bunch of money
and like Anthony key to still freaking
teach you how to no no is it a TV show
we're talking about rock alone no you
could it's a thing you can do like if
you pay enough money you can pay enough
money I'm probably even
a wrong example I don't know that
Anthony Kiedis actually did this
or baseball fantasy camp where you can
go and like participate in the training
camp of this team if you pay enough
money it's kind of like that but it also
has this really deeper component which
to me is the more important part because
it's like MMA is really not a very
accessible sport
it's amazing sport it's a life-changing
sport it's changed my life I'm sure it's
changed your life it's really hard to
rock up to a gym
just coming off the streets and feel
like oh I can I can do this super scary
there's a whole
portion of the population out there that
would love to know what it's like to
train MMA though great and would benefit
from there's your loaded fries by ours I
mean our french fries also kind of my
local price but you can have it but it's
okay
um I agree so it's a program where they
take basically it's kind of like from
Joe's to Pros so it's anyone who wanted
to be involved in mixed martial arts
they get the world-class trainers and
gyms they tell you I know how many
people are involved in it but two of my
guys are and they have to commit for 20
weeks Monday through Friday 7 A.M and
they get world-class training just like
a real fighter would get and at the end
once they go through all the training it
could just be you know they're going in
shape or get more confidence or whatever
ditch the the double chin whatever it is
but for a lot of them they can take a
smoker amateur fight at the end I think
both my guys are going to do it I'm
going to Corner them and if you lose
you're gonna lose your job so there's
there's a caveat that I want to throw in
and put a little prep like I want you to
feel the UFC pressure okay I'm gonna
yell at you like getting away I can't
wait to hear the the speech in between
rounds like that minute oh it's gonna be
yeah
it's gonna be intense you want to pay
your bills yeah yeah you want to come to
work on Monday or knock this beep and
it's just beep beep it's gonna be great
um it's yeah I think it's cool it's so
cool because my experience was not like
overly welcoming like when I would rock
up to an MMA gym and this allows
the accountant the mom the whoever to go
you know what
I like watching the UFC you know I
wonder what it would be like to to train
like those men and women and it Bridges
the gap between that thought process and
the actual experience of doing it and
the story like to me
the story is coming out of the people
that have been through this program and
things that they have achieved in their
own life are absolutely incredible like
there was there was a woman in I can't
remember if it was one of the Australia
programs or if it was here domestically
but like had a really difficult past um
had it been the subject of uh sexual
abuse and like had all sorts of really
difficult baggage in her life and it was
starting to affect her marriage to where
she couldn't be intimate with her
husband oh man prior to her getting
married yeah and then it started and
then just like weirdest ugly head yeah
and she
literally through training MMA
specifically the Jiu Jitsu portion of it
worked through all of the mental blocks
that she had
to where she could actually have a
normal marriage an intimate marriage
with her husband again like that's how
transformative
MMA training can be I'm not saying
everybody's you know experience is going
to be that dramatic but look it's it's
life-changing no my boy Tito George was
460 pounds and his goal is to fight
Conor McGregor that's how that that's
literally he wants to finish this
program and [ __ ] fight it was 460.
460. that's amazing 460 am I off on that
Mike was he 460.
upper Force insane that's incredible
yeah it's transformative I don't know
like I have I don't know a lot about
your motivations about I know you
obviously the background in football but
like for me
I never wanted to fight I just I loved
what the what the training did for my
mental health say so I just enjoyed the
training and all of a sudden I was The
Ultimate Fighter I'm like okay I guess I
fight grown men and steel cage them
underwear for money I've got some John
Claude Van Damme from Lionheart now yeah
even though I have a double degree okay
let's do it you know it's terrifying it
is terrified but but facing that facing
that fear and like oh I want you to do
it for anything yeah no it gave me the
tools to get through today now uh I
thought what else was interesting about
you doing my research on you is part of
me was like why would you even
acknowledge that but you've you've
brought up on interviews before the hate
you get on social media
and I don't think anyone in this world
gets more hate than an attractive girl
who's also successful
it's like these trolls who've never had
girlfriends it just triggers the [ __ ] I
don't know I think because maybe they
didn't get the hot girl in high school
this is their moment to fire back at
them yeah you've even received death
threats
I've got my share of death threats and a
buddy of mine who's way more famous like
oh that's how you know you've kind of
made it I was like oh well I don't want
to make it then yeah I'm good yeah I
don't have to hire security but yeah so
but for you it's like it's not like it's
a like you're you're if you were
competing I get it right because maybe
you beat someone and that person's from
whatever this city so those that City's
upset that you know but for you it's
like okay because I'm doing commentating
and analyst work and yeah I think a lot
of people it's a weird double-edged
sword because it's like on one hand
I'll get
you only have your job because of how
you look and I'm always like listen we
live in the Instagram world I'm not that
hot there are 50 million other
younger better looking girls in bikinis
on Instagram it cannot be for that
reason that's true I mean the Victoria's
Secret models be freaking president it
doesn't make sense and then at the same
time it's like so it's like either you
only got your job you're hot or you look
a certain way and there's no [ __ ]
possibility that you have any idea what
you're talking about right because they
don't
they don't see that side of me so I've
been really intentional in the last
couple years in terms of like posting
more training and posting demo videos I
do of Jiu Jitsu interesting I've tried
really hard to paint a different name
yeah yeah that being said like I'm not
I'm afraid of a good thirst trap like I
mean yeah I'm not denying that yeah at
all yeah I'd have nothing to thirst trap
people with but I I get why you would do
it yeah to say but yeah it's it's
interesting I have like three more years
left of third strapping and then we're
bottling up we're shutting that door
because it's gonna get awkward if I'm
like in my mid-40s yeah it sounds like
15 and you're yeah his buddies like dude
man yeah no it is dicey I think too
you know even though you show those
Jiu-Jitsu videos you could show a video
of you head kicking Anderson Silva and
be like this you don't know how to fight
it's just some of it's their own
insecurities yeah it helps strange I've
had people
I've had guys DM me like
I hope you get raped I hope you kill
yourself and that guy is a winner let me
think about that think about well
sending that I can't imagine well
there's no way he's doing good no I
and I like to I would like to think it's
purely for the like he just wants to say
something so outlandish that he thinks I
can't resist responding to it and I
never I shouldn't say never every once
in a while I can't help myself my
husband always like slaps my it's like
stop acknowledging that those people
even yeah you don't you never want to
feed the trolls it's hard that's what a
weird thing you know think about that
yeah it's messed up but I will say this
too
as much as that as much of that as I get
I've been genuinely
surprised pleasantly surprised by
General fan reception about me taking
this role that really
is not it hasn't been done before where
you've had a woman in like a very
specific
Lane the reporter Lane is like you're
good at television you're probably a
girl you don't really need to know the
fight game in order to be able to do it
you need to be good at television which
I really wasn't like I kind of forced
myself to be
um they've never had someone in that
role that had enough of a fight
background where they could transition
into being someone who has an opinion
yeah worthy of listening to so sometimes
like the NFL have those female silent
reporters and they'll be like okay what
do you think you're like these guys are
sweating like back to you you know it's
like that but she's like the attractive
girl yeah these guys are really
breathing Hard Out Here Gary though
thank you thank you back throw it back
to Keith you know so like that silent
reporter role you're really not there to
have an opinion you're there to uh relay
information that you've gathered from
other people yeah you're not there to
have an opinion and I and I remember
like I would find these random
opportunities to try to like insert my
fight knowledge and I would start
breaking down you know 5 a little bit
too much in the reports and be like you
need to stop you're just like please
stop stop you're a reporter please stop
um so it's it was hard to go from like
this is who you are this is what you do
to this new Lane where they haven't had
well they've obviously never had a
female commentator that's right
man that like
even you saying it like that I would go
one further than say the Hoist Gracie
right let's not right why not he was the
first you're the first
you know I appreciate you yeah you're
the first yeah this is no Rhonda without
Gina Carano that's a good point no
that's a good point um but I get it no I
I remember when he said that and like I
I actually have that clip like saved in
my phone yeah I think I was worried that
people wouldn't
uh allow me to shift from host reporter
into this like role where like oh we
want to listen to what she says not just
be like oh she's they wouldn't even have
the jobs yeah like if you weren't who
you were it would be a tough gig you
know what I'm saying like you didn't
have the traps weren't able to do it
it'd be a rough goat oh but you do so
it's right here it helps it like the
guys that I work with as I talk with my
mouth full but it helps with the guys I
work with the best things the
Paul's the DC's of the world yeah
they'll love you
they they have been so supportive yes so
supportive and the most I mean and the
most supportive person of all has been
Dana so like
the combination of the guys that I sit
next to
being like all right you're cool you're
like you can we get it you know it took
a while though to earn that from them
usually I keep showing up and doing your
job yeah that's what you're doing yeah
and also those guys you know they're not
easy crowd Pleasers like if you weren't
good you would know yeah especially with
Bisbee you would know you would know I
love Mike yeah when I first like really
dug into this mission of being the first
it I'll be honest with you it was like
my competitive Spirit my
internal individual personal drive but
it was not it wasn't very long at all
after I kind of like set out on this
Mission then I realized it was about way
way more than that and I know that
sounds like super cheesy but I've had
dad's message me and they're like you
know I was watching the UFC and you came
on television and my daughter walked in
the room was like who's this and he said
and it literally opened up an
opportunity for me to have a
conversation with her about like you
know you can you can enter these Arenas
where it's a male-dominated situation
and you can still have a place if you do
it right yep and I'm not skills I'm you
have to have the skills it's number one
of course it is and it's not like I am
definitely not what you would call a
traditional feminist like you probably
have spent enough time around me just
for you to realize like
my personality is like I'm kind of like
one of the guys I was raised around my
older brother and Jim's too in Kansas
City yeah older brother yeah but at the
same time
um I have kind of realized that like it
that representation does matter and the
sport is male and female like the UFC is
so special to me because it's the only
sport unlike the WNBA in the NBA which
is totally different yeah
where they're together and they train
together and to me that's the biggest
thing is like the men have respect for
the women and vice versa because they
they're training together in the gym but
it's also like you look at the WNBA like
there's no one even I mean lately just
because she's in prison Russia has
gotten a lot of attention like Brittany
Greiner but compared to the like LeBron
James like there's nowhere in the you
know female Debian babe there's no
Superstar there's like globally like
kids are buying their merch stuff like
that I think when Rondo is fighting I'm
talking yeah we we were hanging out that
we were talking the most famous fighter
man or woman yes ever at the time I'm
close yeah that's how cool it is it is
and I think that watching a woman do
something that is so outside of the
norms and especially when because she
looked the way she did she just kicked
all the she just blew outside of that
box that people would want to you know
to put her in and to see her go out
there and just Dominate and do it so
beautifully and consistently and and
that's why they call you the Ronda
Rousey of commentating that's what Dana
said I can't think enough for doing the
show the fries are cold now I'm still
gonna eat the burger had too much bun I
will have some it's too much fun but it
was a tasty burger I can't think enough
no thank you the next time when you um
do the pay-per-view you gotta flight
straight back to here now we don't let
anybody go without you know I'm a
sneakerhead I don't give every guest a
sneaker that comes on now these I got
you
um I'm sorry I couldn't just stop
playing chew because you're not a plain
girl and so uh you know Kanye West is an
outlier and you're an outlier and these
aren't just any species
yeah stop so these are gonna be wrong oh
my God can I tell you something sure I
have been wanting Yeezys for the longest
time and have not had the balls I just
didn't think I could carry it off you
definitely can but your Superstar was a
superstar shoe and Kanye's Superstar he
designed them so this is for my boys at
suplex in Philly that said Laura senko
please wear and enjoy the zz350 zebras
big big fans over here at the shop if
you're in Philly be sure to stop in then
they give their address there's a
picture of one of them just kidding as
long as it's up in space
just kidding
she did bring a printer if I have to
ditch the printer I want to keep the
shoes because you want your own printer
because you don't want printers to mess
up yeah it shows how dedicated you are
you're the best come back thank you
thank you please enjoy the easy I will
thank you oh I love it